foreign
oh
pretty
huh
[Music]
right
yes
okay
oh yes
how uh
okay
so she
yes
we can use
you
like
so
much
thank you
okay
i believe
so
you
okay
um
okay
okay
so
um
so
players
um
okay
two-minute warning to the presidential
two-minute warning to the press person
thank you
there we go
now
not available
so
hi everyone hello
happy wednesday don't be distracted by
andrew's fabulous seersucker suit over
here
okay a couple of items for all of you at
the top the present's running a little
bit late too so we'll have a heart out
at about
five or ten after but we'll keep you
honest for those of you who are joining
this event
uh today the biden harris administration
launched the low-income household water
assistance program
a first of its kind water assistance
program that will expand access to more
affordable water
and help low-income households affected
by the covid19 pandemic
pay their water and wastewater bills
avoid shutoffs and support
household water system reconnections
related to
non-payment 166.6 million
or 15 percent of allotted program
funding is being made immediately
available to grantees which will then of
course be distributed in communities
in total 1.1 billion will be available
through grants including 500 million
in american rescue plan funding
president believes that having access to
affordable clean and safe drinking water
is essential to everybody's health and
well-being a little preview of the
president's remarks
for later this afternoon we've now
vaccinated
63 percent of the country and over 72
percent of those 40
and older are vaccinated thanks to
aggressive action
by this administration covet 19 cases
and deaths
have plummeted as a result cases are
down over 90 percent
deaths are down over 85 since january
20th
the fact remains if you're not
vaccinated you're at risk of getting the
virus or spreading it to someone else so
today the president will announce
the launch of a month of action to
mobilize and all of america
sprint to get more people vaccinated by
july
4th community leaders faith partners
businesses celebrities athletes colleges
and thousands of volunteers will
participate in this nationwide campaign
and as part of the month of action we're
making it even easier to get vaccinated
which as we've seen is the key
uh to increasing numbers and getting
more shots and arms
so the nation's largest child care
providers watching will
uh will be watching kids for free while
parents get the shot
vaccines will happen at barber shops
baseball games and nascar races
pharmacies will be open
24 hours on fridays um and throughout
our time in office we've seen we've led
a whole of government effort to get the
vaccine out
so this next month we're continuing to
build on that by
leading canvassing phone banking texting
into areas with low vaccination rates
coordinating vaccine events more than
100 organizations have committed to
hosting
over a thousand events the first weekend
alone
and we're also launching a national
vaccination tour the vice president will
lead a tour
to key communities across the south and
midwest
that will be coming up and we're
launching a mayor's challenge and you've
seen a little bit of a
activity about this already where cities
compete to boost vaccination rates
through canvassing local partnerships
and incentives for people
and through the covid19 college
challenge more than 230 colleges and
universities are taking pledge
uh taking pledge and commit taking a
pledge and committing to take action to
get their students and communities
vaccinated
and finally businesses like
anheuser-busch kroger and doordash
are stepping up to offer all adults free
beer on july 4th
the chance to win a million dollars and
free meals for people who get vaccinated
at community health centers
we've seen krispy kreme has done this i
would not recommend a krispy kreme with
a beer but i'll leave that to other
people to decide
finally the president wants to convey
his heartfelt congratulations to
congresswoman elect
melanie stansberry on her decisive
victory last night marking the first
time
in over 100 years that a special
election has been won by a larger margin
than their party received in the
previous general election uh he looks
forward to working with her
in congress alex why don't you kick us
off sure i have a couple of questions
first on jvs
um can you confirm that the ransom
demand came from
our evil um i know it's a criminal
organization that we faced in russia
and was the uh ransom paid
and then can you speak a little bit
about have you seen any progress on this
call from the government for uh business
and private sector to
work with the federal government in
updating their cyber security measures
sure on the last part i'm not in a place
to confirm the specifics of the ransom
request or the origin obviously our team
is continuing to
evaluate and i would send you to the
company for any specific questions about
the ransom request
i will say that this attack is a
reminder
about the importance to private sector
entities of hardening
uh their cyber security and ensuring
they take the necessary steps to prepare
for this threat which we've seen rising
even over the last few weeks
as it relates to actions we're taking in
the federal government
the president has launched a rapid
strategic review
to address the increased threat of
ransomware to include four
major lines of effort disruption of
ransomware infrastructure and actors
working closely
with the private sector we will work in
partnership with them that is something
that this administration has done
a bit differently than in the past in
working to find best practices ensuring
that
uh private sector entities have a seat
at the table and we can work in close
coordination
building an international coalition to
hold countries who harbor ransom actors
accountable
i mean this attack is an example of how
this is not just a problem in the united
states
these are actors that are working to get
into systems around the world
this was a company obviously based in
brazil but australia was a major
uh was impacted also by this
uh expanding cryptocurrency analysis
obviously this has been an
increasing question out there to find
and pursue criminal transactions
and reviewing our own ransomware
policies so
this is an internal policy process
essentially one that's looking at all of
these entities
uh within our national security economic
team
and then on the president's comments
yesterday he seemed to
call out a mansion in cinema for he said
voting more for
with republicans than democrats but um
replica
actually found that they've so far both
voted with biden 100
of the time on major votes um and so can
you explain where those comments came
from and why he felt the need to call
out members of his own party
well i would say first that if senator
manchin and senator cinema were standing
with me here today
they're always welcome they would call
out their own independent streaks and
that's something that i think they're
both proud of
they both vote for and represent the
people in the states
uh that and all the people who elected
them uh to represent them in the senate
uh if you look at what the senate the
president said the big tell here is
i hear all the folks on tv saying now as
a former tv pundit myself
um i can tell you that sometimes these
conversations can be
oversimplified tv isn't always made for
complex conversations about policy
making we all know that
right and what the president was simply
conveying is that
uh he his uh threshold his litmus test
is not to see eye to eye on every single
detail of every issue
uh and he doesn't with senator cinema
and senator manchin and he doesn't with
senator capito who's coming here
later this afternoon he believes there's
an opportunity to work together
to make progress to find areas of common
ground
uh even if you have areas of
disagreement and he also believes that
sometimes
um because there are three uh entities
uh three branches of government
something he knows well having served 36
years in the senate
that sometimes it's not a straight line
to victory or success
that uh sometimes uh you know it takes
more time and
um you know he's open to many paths for
it so i i don't think he was intending
to convey
other anything other than a little bit
of commentary on tv punditry well
it did seem to suggest that he is in
favor of filibuster reform and wants to
see that
move so why hasn't he been more
prominent in
calling for that and is he pressuring
manchin and cinema to move on that issue
privately
i wouldn't say that that his comments
yesterday
were conveying a new position on his
view on the filibuster his full
comment was by saying that manchin and
cinema are standing
in the way of his agenda essentially
what was he referencing that's not
exactly what he said i think it's
important to quote him directly what he
said was
uh i hear all the folks on tv saying why
doesn't biden get this done
well because biden only has a majority
of effectively four votes in the house
and a tie in the senate with two members
of the senate who vote more with my
republican friends
he's not he was not giving a specific
commentary on a policy
he was conveying again that sometimes
that's the summary
shorthand version that he sees on
uncable news at times
again it's not always the forum that's
easy to provide guidance on how bill
becomes a law
uh his view on the filibuster continues
to be
that there should be a path forward for
democrats and republicans to make voting
easier
to move forward on progress for the
american people that
position hasn't changed and he was not
intending to convey something different
go ahead thank you back on the
ransomware attack uh
is the u.s going to retaliate and
realistically what options are on the
table is a counter-attack
an option sure well one let me say um
not to get ahead of your line of
questioning but i assume this will be a
question
so we do expect this to be one of the
issues that
uh the president will discuss with
president putin at the summit
uh that will be two weeks from today if
my if my calendar is correct in my mind
and in terms of considerations of you
know we're not taking any options off
the table
in terms of how we may respond but of
course there's an internal policy review
process to consider that
uh we're in direct touch with the
russians as well uh to convey
uh our concerns about these reports you
mentioned the meeting
um when it comes to this issue what does
success
look like at that discussion what are
you looking to accomplish when the
president
walks away from that table when it comes
to cyber security
well first let me uh say that you know
this is an issue
that we have discussed with the russian
government the specific issue and we've
discussed it in the past and delivered
the message that
responsible states do not harbor
ransomware criminals
as we've also noted from here and i
noted in the beginning
obviously ransomware attacks we've seen
them increase uh over
a period of time it's an increasing
threat to the private sector and to our
critical infrastructure and there are
other countries
many of whom we will see when the
president is in europe who have similar
concerns so we expect this to be an
issue of discussion throughout the
president's trip i will say
in terms of what success looks like
coming out of the summit
i can't predict that at this point in
time but i can convey to you that
this will certainly be a topic of
discussion that harboring criminal
entities that are intending to do harm
that are doing harm to the critical
infrastructure in the united states is
not acceptable we're not going to stand
by that we will raise that and we are
not going to take options off the table
and in those conversations with the
russian government so far do you get a
sense that they are taking this
seriously
are they going to be taking steps to try
and stop these
bad actors i am as i've said before i'm
blissfully not a spokesperson for the
kremlin uh so i will let them speak for
themselves but
i can assure you that we are raising
this um
through highest levels of the us
government it will be a topic of
discussion and direct
uh one-on-one discussions or direct
discussions with president putin and
president
biden happening in just a couple of
weeks and
certainly uh protecting our own
infrastructure in the united states is
of utmost
national security importance just one
more on this topic because the russians
are outlining some of the things they
would also
like to discuss during the summit the
foreign minister lavrov indicated
that russia wants to be discussing human
rights violations in the u.s
saying uh they're following with
interest the persecution of those
persons who are accused
of the riots on january 6 this year i'm
wondering
what you make of that where you think
this is coming from well we don't
use the russian government as our guide
to human rights
models in the world but i will say that
the president has not
held back in his view that the attacks
on january 6 were
a mark on democracy or dark day in our
own democracy uh and certainly
i'm sure he'd be happy to repeat that
but the president's view is that there
are a range of topics uh of just that we
should be discussing uh in this
meeting we'll have more to preview uh
for it uh
probably in the days in advance of the
summit including uh
on his agenda is of course uh these uh
cyber attacks and the use of ransomware
harboring criminal
entities in your own country also is
their aggressive actions uh in ukraine
uh and also uh is are areas where there
can be an opportunity to work together
including
uh nuclear capabilities and security so
lots to discuss go ahead just to put a
fine point on this very quickly is it
president biden's view that
president putin can stop these attacks
these hacks from occurring if he wanted
to
well i would say the president uh
president biden certainly thinks that uh
president putin and the russian
government has a role to play
in uh stopping and preventing these
attacks hence it's a
it will be a topic of discussion when
they meet in two weeks does the
president believe that
vladimir putin is testing him right now
ahead of the summit
i'm not going to give any further
analysis on that other than to tell you
that
uh our view uh is that uh when there are
criminal entities within a country
they certainly have a responsibility uh
and it is a role that the government can
play and again that will be a discussion
at the summit
of all the threats that the white house
has to juggle right now of course there
are a lot how high does
ransomware fall on that list right now
has it gone dramatically higher in the
course of
this administration does it need to be
higher than it is right now where is it
you know how i love rank ordering our
our focuses and our threats
right this is now that is true and and
peter i just said that i i think that
this is uh this attack that we've seen
over the last couple of days
and certainly uh following the attack
that we saw several weeks ago
is also a reminder to the private sector
about the need and the importance of
hardening their own cybersecurity
protections of investing in
and putting in place uh protections in
their own systems
we have given guidance for some time
from the federal government and it is up
to a number of these private sector
entities to protect themselves as well
the steamship authority in massachusetts
reports that they were just
the victims of a hack has that been
communicated to the white house are you
involved do you have any comment or
message or
anybody to attribute that to uh i have
seen those reports i they
they just came out yes exactly i just
don't have anything more for you on it
but we can see if there's more later
this afternoon
if i can then in march we heard from the
national security adviser jake sullivan
who came in here and told us that
the u.s in the near future to his you to
use his words
would name who's responsible for the
hack on the microsoft
exchange so can you tell us who that is
most several months
have passed and what the hold up might
be i'm happy to check with our national
security team and see if they have an
update
as you know they are quite careful and
thorough i should say
thorough is probably the right word and
how they review and assess and provide
public guidance but we can see if
there's anything more they can report
out
is the prevailing theory still that it's
china or can you not go any further than
he did that i don't think i have an
update on it from what we've provided in
the past
go ahead thanks jen why does the white
house think there's a shortage of
workers right now well we've talked
about this a bit in the past
but happy to go through it um so
one i our view is that um uh
it's going to take time for workers to
regain confidence in the safety of the
workplace
reestablish child care school and
commuting arrangements and finish
getting vaccinated and even when
individuals
get their first dose we've seen a huge
increase in that as i started the
briefing talking about
it's about a five to six week cycle so
we have expected that to have an
impact at the same time as we look at
all of the data
uh we know that our economy is growing
uh faster than any time
than any time in the last 40 years we're
creating an average of 500 000
jobs a month up from 60 000 a month
before
uh the president took office and we're
continuing to put in place policies and
measures
to ensure that we're helping people make
ends meet and we're helping the economy
continue to grow
but and you mentioned thoughts about
safety you're celebrating the number of
vaccinations today you say the vaccines
work cold cases are way down you're
right
is is there any thought here that some
of the workers shortage could be driven
by
the extra 300 in weekly unemployment
benefits through september i will say
peter that our economist and our
assessment and the
assessment of many economists out there
is that the impact the largest impact
are on issues related to the pandemic
and yes you're right that the increased
numbers that's a good science a positive
sign
but it's a five to six week cycle so
this the data that was taken for the may
jobs number
the jobs numbers that came out for april
in early may was from early april that's
almost two months ago
right we'll see we'll have jobs numbers
come out on friday
people the vaccination rates are
continuing to go up and in terms of
people being fully safe
fully vaccinated it's going to take some
time we always expected that to be a
couple of months and
we expect to see continuing improvement
in the numbers on the jbs hack
these hackers based in russia have
disrupted american gas
supplies and american meat supplies why
do you think
that these ransomware attacks have been
rising since
president buying for office well first i
would say these are private sector
entities
uh who have a responsibility to put in
place measures to protect their own
cyber security
as it relates to why criminal actors are
taking actions against private sector
entities
i don't think i'm the right one to speak
to that total coincidence
i think you could certainly go track
down those uh cyber criminals in russia
and have a
a good chat with them if you have any
leads we'll take that
okay and then on immigration has the
president or the vice president
seen the video from last friday a
five-year-old boy dropped off along the
border yelling to the adults
who abandoned him no no don't go
no well i've seen the video it is
heartbreaking
and the reason we continue to be very
clear regularly migrating to the united
states puts ourselves and others
at risk that's why we relate relaunch
certain efforts to build a more fair and
orderly immigration system
including programs like the central
american minors program that allows kids
who are eligible to apply from within
country but i don't think anyone whether
a parent or not would watch that video
and not feel heartbroken uh by a
five-year-old i think
screaming uh at the border go ahead
thanks jen um a couple questions about
the coveted numbers
um you talked about the the latest
vaccination rates
does the vitamin administration still
consider
herd immunity to be realistic and
achievable
well i would say first that dr fauci has
spoken to this and the kind of
terminology of herd immunity
and kind of refuted that as the right
definition of how we should look to how
we're going to make progress and that's
why we have
set out a goal of getting 70 percent
of the american population vaccinated by
july 4. there's still a lot of work to
do about a dozen states have
met that requirement that's why we're
launching this
um big initiative over the past over the
next month but what dr fauci and other
medical experts have conveyed is that
it's really going to be up to
local communities and states to see what
their vaccination rate is
uh and make determinations about what's
going to work locally it's
that is how the assessments will need to
be made you talked about the 90
drop in cases does the white house worry
that as the number of cases drops that
these holdouts will actually be
more reluctant to get vaccinated because
they won't be as worried
that they themselves will get sick well
first
that's one of the reasons we're
continuing to reiterate that if you're
not vaccinated
you are not safe uh you're not safe
against others who are not
vaccinated who may carry the virus the
individuals who can benefit from
all of the new guidance the cdc has put
out who can go to concerts and
go to baseball games i was gonna say
football not quite there yet
go to their kids soccer games and not
wear a mask those are vaccinated
individuals there's huge incentives to
getting vaccinated
but it doesn't mean that individuals who
are not vaccinated
are safe from getting the virus and well
yes we've made a lot of progress
there are still communities where the
percentage is higher than it should be
where there are still larger numbers of
young adults who are not vaccinated
those are many of the communities that
we're focused on in our
month-long effort in the president's
speech yesterday when he laid out
his new economic equity measures one of
the things he didn't talk about was
student loan forgiveness
and that's something he talked about a
lot on the campaign trail we know that
student debt is a big driver in racial
economic inequality so why didn't he
include that and where where does the
white house want to go on that issue
well first i would say that um one of
the ways
anyone can know out there about how much
the president cares about student debt
and student loans is by
simply looking at his budget and the
budget he proposed and rolled out
last friday he makes two years of
community college free
along with a major increase in pell
grants that will drastically reduce the
cost of an education beyond high school
the american families plan which he
proposed we still need to get it of
course and
signed into law or passed and signed
into law which is included also in the
president's budget includes a historic
47 billion
of investments in hbcu's tribal colleges
and universities
and minority serving institutions and
these institutions are critical to
helping
underrepresented students move to the
top of the income ladder
and so president biden is calling for a
historic investment in these areas and
those are things that are laid out
specifically in his budget and shows his
desire and commitment to
level the playing field and provide
necessary assistance
why doesn't the budget include ten
thousand dollars in student loan
debt forgiveness for example that's
something that he called on congress to
do when he was a candidate and he'd be
happy to sign a bill into law
if they passed that bill and he'd look
forward to having it on his desk
thanks go ahead thank you john just a
couple of follow-ups on jvs
obviously the white house is engaging
directly
with russia on this uh and we were
wondering if russia has offered
any cooperation or or help in tracking
down these hackers
i'm just not going to be reading out
russia's view or their
role here you can certainly ask them
those questions and
and considering this is obviously the
third russia-linked attack
this year um and we understand that the
president will bring this up in his
meeting with president putin
is the administration really considering
any actions in addition to that
just to make sure that this doesn't
happen uh sanctions or any other actions
that are perhaps on the table
sure i mean as i said i think in
response to an earlier question we're
not taking options
off of the table but it's just an
opportunity there will be an opportunity
for the president to discuss this
directly with president
putin to reiterate the fact that we
believe that
responsible states do not harbor
ransomware criminals
and that and as he said um as we said
around uh colonial in the colonial hack
or the colonial ransomware attack
uh we will continue to be in direct
touch with moscow we will continue
uh to make the case that uh responsible
countries need to take decisive action
against ransomware
networks uh at the same time as i noted
a little bit earlier too
we're doing our own review of a range of
options as well from here
and i have one on on the surplus
vaccines
sure has there been any decision made on
on those 80 million vaccines and will
the president offer any updates on that
today
uh he won't offer any updates on that
today uh hopefully we'll have more for
you on that soon i know there's a lot of
interest and as i've noted earlier or
previously
what we want to do is not just convey
hopefully some of where some of the
vaccine may be going
but also what our approach will be to
ensure that it is distributed in an
equitable
manner around the world so all of that
would be a part of any
announcement at the appropriate time go
ahead
thanks john uh during the campaign uh
biden promised to host a summit for
democracy during the first year of his
presidency
can you give us an update on if that's
taking place when it might
take place i don't have any date or
schedule for you uh we have some time
left in the year
fortunately um but i don't have any
update for you on the timing he's
planning to do it in his first year that
that still remains the plan
can you say anything more about the
specific mandate that the president gave
to the vice president on voting
sure yesterday i mean is there how has
he been a measure success
on that well first let me say that uh
the president sees the vice president as
an
important partner and somebody who can
work to take on challenging
and hard initiatives that's the role of
the modern day vice president
and she actually asked to run point and
lead
on voting rights it's an issue that she
is personally committed to
and passionate about as she conveyed in
her statement uh yesterday
she expects in the week weeks ahead to
engage not just with the american people
but with voting rights organizations
community organizations the private
sector to help strengthen up
uplift efforts on voting rights
nationwide
that includes working with members of
congress certainly to move
legislation forward something the
president strongly supports it also
includes working with local
organizations working with states to see
how to make voting
more accessible to uh people across the
country so
i think the president is looking to work
with the vice president and as a partner
and and looking forward to her taking on
this important initiative something
that's a priority
to him as well and i'm sure he'll be
regularly updated on her progress
expect the vice president to travel to
these states that have imposed
voting restrictions and in their state
laws i think the vice president will
have more to say
about what how she will approach this
effort as you know she's traveling to
the northern triangle
over the next couple of days on one of
the other initiatives she's leading but
i expect she'll have more to say
in the coming weeks briefly how does he
expect the vice president to prioritize
these
multiple things that she has and her
in her in our agenda well
i would say just as the president has to
balance a number of different priorities
whether it's the american jobs plan or
working to protect us from ransomware
attacks or
preparing for an international summit
and
all of the other entities that are on
the president's plate a modern day vice
president does the same thing
so he's confident in her ability to
take on a robust agenda which she
certainly has on her plate
go ahead yeah thanks jen i'm curious if
you can kind of
see that sorry go ahead it's okay go
ahead oh so chivalrous there
go ahead okay
describe for us how thin is the
president's patience when it comes to
negotiating some of these
bipartisan agreements he wants to see
not just with infrastructure today but
for example whether it's
police reform or the jobs plan at some
point
does he say to his fellow democrats we
just have to go at it alone
and then does that mean we're going to
see more executive orders as a result
well first um i would say that the
president has a bit of experience
legislating
um and his approach is to
look for means ways we can find common
ground that's exactly what he's going to
do
when he meets with senator capito this
afternoon
negotiations mean both sides continue to
make moves toward each other both sides
continue to look for
areas where they agree and that's what
he's prepared to do and he's hopeful
this meeting is an opportunity to do
at the same time we're working on a
number of different paths there's
uh discussions between bipartisan
members in the senate about
uh how they might come to agreement on a
path forward on
uh a historic investment in
infrastructure
on a version of the american jobs plan
he's eager to see what they have to
offer
we also know next week us congressman
defazio is going to be marking up the
american jobs plan
in the house something a lot of members
and democrats in the house are quite
excited about so
i would say that we're working on many
channels
um he's going to have discussions with
all of these entities and parties and
uh he knows that sometimes in this
journey in this path
you have to keep a range of options on
the table of patients
i would say he wouldn't have been in the
senate for 36 years if he wasn't quite
patient
so uh but you know him patience is not
uh unending
and he wants to make progress his only
line in the sand
is in action he wants to sign a bill
into law this summer
but i would also remind you that the
american rescue plan
passed in a very quick timeline for how
legislation moves forward very fast
and there's historic legislation the
affordable care act for example the
fight the president worked closely on
that took a year we're not advising
that's the timeline but just to suggest
that sometimes these efforts
uh can take a little bit of time he's
working to move things forward
and there are certainly items on uh you
know the clock is certainly ticking
because there are items like the markup
next week that will will drive
discussion
uh by members of congress go ahead so
the president has talked a lot about
seeing democracy is under attack and his
speech monday i think was pretty blunt
about that he talked a lot about voting
rights in that speech
can you just clarify how he sees the
stakes of these bills like in texas does
he truly see them as an existential
threat to democracy
well i would say that first he believes
that the texas legislation is a
part of a concerted attack on our
democracy
being advanced as we see have seen not
just in texas as you well know but in
states
across the country on the basis of the
same repeatedly disproven lies
that led to the assault on our nation's
capital on january 6th
so that is of course of great concern to
the president he
thinks that must stop it must be easier
not harder for all eligible voters to
vote
to register and cast their ballots we
need to move forward and not
backward and the fact of the matter is
that the texas legislation would make it
harder to vote
in a state where it is already too hard
for many people to vote but it's not the
only state where we're seeing
this troubling trend but this is one of
the reasons why he asked his vice
president or he
she asked for it but he uh certainly was
uh was uh
uh thrilled to have her leading the
effort on voting rights moving forward
given this is a huge priority to him and
a huge priority to her as well
questionably much different scope of a
follow-up on the free beer announcement
can you just clarify because
anheuser-busch says this is in
partnership with the white house can you
clarify what that means is like the
federal government's subsidizing this at
all
and also are there any concerns that
this is kind of the way that they're
going about this would like upload a
picture of yourself if there's any sort
of data harvesting aspect of this
promotion
well uh i think all the in partnership
means is that we've been encouraging
private sector entities to take actions
to incentivize people to
get vaccinated given we know that will
ensure that more americans have shots in
their arms
are safe are healthy and communities can
return
back to normal uh you know obviously as
it relates we take
data security and people's privacy
incredibly seriously
and certainly if there was an area of
concern we would speak out against that
but we
have seen a number of these actions by
private sector companies be
quite effective and more shots in arms
is a good thing go ahead caitlin
the meeting with senator capito today
should we expect president biden to give
her any kind of deadline for a major
breakthrough on these talks to happen
i wouldn't expect this meeting to be an
exchange of paper
um it would be more of a discussion and
certainly we'll see what comes out of
the meeting and what the appropriate
next step is uh but i don't know
i'm not gonna pre-determine that before
the meeting even begins should we expect
it to be one-on-one or will white house
staff be in the room
i would expect at least a portion of it
to be one-on-one
if not if not the whole meeting but i
can check on that for you too okay and
just to follow up on your comments on
what president biden said about senator
manchin and senator cinema are you
saying that that was not
a criticism of the two of them it was
not
no that he considers them both friends
he considers them both
good working partners uh and he also
believes that
in democracy we don't have to see eye to
eye on every detail of every single
issue in order to work together and he
certainly thinks uh that reflects their
relationship but you've been saying
two democrats vote with republicans more
than they do with my republican friends
i would say that the fact that the
president is having senator capito here
today and has been having ongoing
discussions with republicans
in the senate and that he's eager to
find a path forward on
bipartisan work certainly tells you i
think what you need to know about what
he thinks about
working with people even when there's
disagreement
go ahead just a few quick ones um the
naacp
criticized vitamins plan uh as was
mentioned earlier about not including
the cancellation of
student debt um in april ron plain uh
said that the president asked the
education department to prepare a memo
and wiping out that
executive action and said hopefully
we'll see that in the next few weeks
is there any update on that memo about
kind of
what the president might do on that
front i don't have an update it was
department of education but also a legal
uh review as well um okay and then one
question on on
israel does biden have a view on naftali
bennett's past statements about annexing
the west bank
and negating a two-state solution how
about an approach
clear differences there on an issue and
does he still think he has a partner
for peace uh in an israeli government
led by bennett
well we're not going to weigh in on an
ongoing political process in a foreign
country
in israel or anywhere in the world i
think you probably know well what the
president's view is on a two-state
solution and how he believes it's the
only path forward for lasting peace in
the region and then just
a quick follow-up do you know if bennett
and biden have met
before they've heard kind of contraction
in person
uh it's a good question i i don't know
if they have met in the past or uh have
a prior relationship
go ahead uh president biden campaigned
on ending the federal death penalty
what is he going to take steps to do
that uh he has
he did campaign on that and has talked
about his views on the death penalty i
don't have any update on any forward
action
his delay they're a sign that perhaps
he doesn't feel as strongly about this
uh as maybe he
sounded when he was campaigning i don't
think it's a sign of that there's a
legal process and a department of
justice process uh that
uh would be uh would be standard in any
scenario here he changed his mind on the
death penalty because
he changed his mind bill expanded
the amount of the crime instead he spoke
to this pretty extensively on the
campaign and that's his position i think
we're gonna have to move on go ahead
um i wanted to just given what you said
that his position hasn't changed on the
filibuster
just want to go back to the vote last
week in the senate on the january 6th
commission the fact that there were 54
yes votes
35 no votes the bill failed this is
an insurrection that the president has
called an unprecedented assault
i'm curious if that math makes sense to
this president and
and if that outcome would be acceptable
should it repeat
later this month when the senate takes
off when you say the math makes sense
what do you mean by that i mean the fact
that 54
lawmakers in the senate voted yes 35
voted no
and the bill did not pass well i would
say first that the president doesn't see
a reason for anyone to have voted
against that bill so he doesn't
understand
that version of the math as a starting
point uh he continues to believe that
given that was a dark day in our
democracy a day that
i think we will all remember he will
remember certainly
as president as a day that does not
stand out
as a model of what is possible in this
country
in terms of his view of the filibuster
you know again
his position has not changed on that he
does want to see accountability as it
relates to and he does want to see an
assessment of what happened to prevent
it from ever happening
again and he is happy to talk with
members of congress about
how to approach that moving forward as
you all know
uh no president can wave a wand
and uh pass a piece of legislation with
50 votes when it requires 60 that
requires
congress to move forward with that
action it seems like it requires
only one more democratic vote than
currently exists for that and that vote
happens to be a person who the president
did seem to single out yesterday so
you're saying that he didn't change his
position
on the filibuster and yet you know he's
saying things yeah i mean his passion
for voting rights was evident yesterday
when he spoke he's saying we must find
the courage in quoting him
to change the things we know we can
change so
i just want to be very sure that you're
saying that should that outcome repeat
itself later this month
if the senate takes up voting rights
more than 50 lawmakers vote for a bill
but the bill does not advance to his
desk is that something he's going to be
okay living with again i don't think the
president is okay
with the january 6 commission not being
in place he's not okay with voting
rights uh
not passing and he will continue to
advocate for both moving forward
go ahead yes as the president prepared
for the summit
with the leaders of the nato some
reports you know surfaced regarding
spying on
on germany how would that affect the
summit
and uh that like the establishment of
the u.s
nato relations i think you're referring
to the
reports from 2014 correct uh
that that dated back to um i will say my
last time in government um
i don't i wouldn't say that um you know
in 2014
uh let me say we issued a full the
united states issued a full review of
our approach to overseas
surveillance uh president obama at that
time
issued a presidential directive that
changed our approach in significant ways
so that is a lot that has happened since
between the la over the last seven years
and we will continue
to work with our european allies and
partners to address any questions
through the appropriate
national security channels but i can
tell you that president biden will be
able to reassure
president merkel and president macron
about
current u.s posture and uh you know
certainly we look forward to working
together on a range of
prime minister who said that you know he
would stand against
any agreement between uh you know with
iran even if that would
you know cause trouble with you know the
israeli-american relations
is there any reaction from the white
house regarding that
sorry the first part of your question
was what it was about
netanyahu said that like he would uh
stand against
any agreement on you know on iran
and you know even if that would you know
result in like tension with uh you know
american israeli relations
that's consistently been the prime
minister's position uh
and what our responsibility is and the
responsibility of president biden is to
act in the interest of the united states
and our view is that
putting in place a diplomatic agreement
an agreement where we can prevent iran
from acquiring a nuclear weapon where we
have
returned to the visibility we had before
the former president pulled out of that
deal is in our interests so we will
continue to
uh work and and brief uh the leaders in
israel as we have over the last several
years but
our position hasn't changed
you know the israelis requested a
billion dollar you know in
military aid after what had just
happened you know is the united states
willing to
and prepare to provide that aid uh
the president conveyed that uh at his
press conference he did with the
uh leader of south korea just a few
weeks ago that nothing has changed about
our
intention to provide assistance to the
israeli government and
also our desire and interest in
providing
humanitarian and security assistance to
the palestinians as well so i expect
this will continue
i don't have any assessment of any new
request go ahead on the vaccination
efforts as
of may 7th only less than seven percent
of the ice detainee population about 22
000 detainees
had been vaccinated where is that
process going the aclu has demanded this
white house be a letter
to speed up that process so if you have
an update and also how do you plan to
vaccinate
eligible unaccompanied minors who are in
uh detention
well on the first question uh
immigration and customs enforcement ice
is
firmly committed to the health and
well-being and welfare of all those in
custody uh covid19 vaccines for ice
detainees are being allocated
by local and state health departments
that's how they are distributed based on
availability and the state's vaccine
implementation plan so that's where they
directly come not from
not directly from the federal government
additionally dhs's
chief medical officer is rapidly working
on scaling our own internal capability
to vaccinate detainees in our care
across the country so that would be an
additional step in addition to the state
and local
allocations but it is a focus and a
priority
in terms of unaccompanied minors some
eligible unaccompanied children have
already
received a covid19 vaccine we're working
with our state partners to implement
broader vaccine distribution
in keeping with cdc guidance it hasn't
been an extensive period of time where
children under the age of 18 have been
eligible
obviously these allocations are
distributed across states but
of course they've been broadly available
for some time in the country so this
should
provide a greater access to the vaccine
to unaccompany children
and is the president aware of the
current situation in nicaragua where the
government is harassing journalists
activists even a presidential candidate
and is claiming
is investigating them for money
laundering in that country with
really no legal basis is he aware is the
state department working on this
i know the state department is and i'd
certainly send you to them on any
specific comment from here obviously we
would speak out
uh against any harassment of journalists
individuals leaders uh
the tra that you know crushing of
freedom of speech expression that it
sounds like it's occurring in this
case okay um all right
thank you everyone uh look forward to
seeing you tomorrow
you